a sad story the breakup of a love story
that is kind of rare coming out of
bachelor nation and by that I mean
bachelor couples don't always see
together as long as this one did Kaitlyn
Bristowe and Shawn booth and of course
she is a former Bachelorette
the two got engaged after he proposed to
her on her season finale there he is and
we have confirmed e.t has just gotten
the statement that the two have split up
after about three years together I'm
just going to go ahead and read the
statement right off my phone we have the
official statement in from Kaitlyn's
manager on behalf of Kaitlyn and Shawn
quote after three incredible years we
have decided to go our separate ways
this difficult decision comes after
thoughtful respectful consideration even
though we are parting as a couple we're
very much committed to remaining friends
we have both evolved as people they say
which is taking us in different
directions they go on but with the hope
that we will continue to support each
other in new ways due to the nature of
how we met
aka on the show our relationship has
always been very public and we have
enjoyed sharing it with all of you but
we ask that you respect our decision and
our privacy at this time so that is a
statement from Kaitlyn and Shawn a joint
statement revealing that they have split
now Brendan this comes after a lot of
speculation you and I had both kind of
been following this story because we
were just texting last night actually
because they've been very separate on
social media lately I pointed out to you
you know Shawn just went to a wedding
over the weekend and Kaitlyn was not
with him at the wedding and look if
you're gonna go to a wedding and you
don't bring your significant other with
you I think people question and wonder
what's going on in fans had noticed how
little time they'd been spending
together just being seen on each other's
instagrams so fans have been asking
about it and Kaitlyn actually not too
long ago addressed it on her podcast off
the vine and said they were still
committed to each other they just had
different obligations so the question
now becomes what went wrong especially
because she had just addressed that what
is the latest reporting that we're
getting in from our different sources so
we have one source that talent is
telling us that nothing specific
happened to cause this split that it was
just a matter of them simply growing
apart
which does happen in relationships we're
told they still care very much about
each other this our source is very
optimistic that the two will remain very
good friends and our source actually
added that it's been very hard but
Caitlyn is very strong and amazing and
she'll be fine and that there'll be new
adventures ahead for these guys now I do
also know we have another source telling
us someone who knows the couple that
they had been estranged essentially for
a couple of weeks and also that you know
Shawn had just gotten this gym you just
opened this gym in Nashville he was
spending a lot of time on that so him
spending time on that it does kind of
coincide with that part of their
statement where they're saying we both
evolved you know I know Caitlyn does her
podcast Shawn has the gym they're both
very busy with different work endeavors
and at the end of the day they were
living together in Nashville but we just
weren't seeing them together too much on
social media and for somebody like them
who post this frequently as they do
again fans were raising eyebrows fans
were asking about it and ultimately
they've released this statement so we
will continue working this story we'll
have to find out what will happen for
them next because they were living
together in this home in Nashville and I
actually spoke to a source a little
while ago who told me that she was
Caitlyn was speaking very highly of
Shawn at a wedding in Malibu here in
California on October 14th which really
if you think about it it's not that long
ago so apparently she was speaking very
highly of him at the wedding so it adds
up to what our other sources have told
us that this appears to be a very
amicable split and they seem to be
friendly still with each other
which is always good all right well they
were a beloved couple of bachelor nation
and again up until this you know they
were considered one of those success
stories but it seems the relationship
has run its course
Brendan thank you so much for joining me
from our 80 news desk
you
[Music]
[Applause]